[Music]
foreign
or go home two teams will punch their
tickets to the Super Bowl this weekend
in the NFC it's the 49ers who travel to
the City of Brotherly Love for a battle
with the Philadelphia Eagles Sunday then
it's a rematch of last year's AFC title
game between the Bengals and the Chiefs
right here on CBS The Great Jim Nance of
CBS Sports will be calling the game from
Kansas City and joins us right now Jim
good morning how you doing
good morning Nate I'm looking forward to
the game this weekend it's a repeat of
last year's championship game and as you
know Cincinnati has played Kansas City
three times in the last year and beating
them every time
some will say that the Bengals have
their number I mean but this is five
consecutive AFC title games for the
Chiefs I mean there are no slouch
themselves but what are you looking
forward to when it comes to this matchup
specifically
I think everybody wants to see how
healthy Patrick Mahomes is going to be
my guess on this I'm going to meet with
him uh later today is that he's going to
be okay with that high ankle sprain he's
had this injury one other time in his
career I happen to have the game right
behind it the following week and he
threw for 443 yards and four touchdowns
so listen we all know you can't come up
with enough superlatives to describe
Patrick Mahomes and I think he's going
to be okay but I think going in
everybody wants to see if he is going to
be himself I believe he will
I wanted to follow up Jim on that on the
ankle question and by the way I just
adore you I was so excited when I heard
you were coming on today thank you but
everybody was watching Patrick Holmes in
his ankle everybody saw that and he was
saying I'm I can play Don't Take Me Out
don't take me out last time I check you
need your ankle to play football right
so what are the Chiefs telling you about
it and can you can you think he can
really play if it's his Bat because it
seems to me it would get worse during
the week not better
well he's been going through treatment
since the game ended on Saturday got an
extra day because they had a Saturday
playoff game every single day helps he
went right into treatment after the game
and the last two days he's been at
practice a full participant and those
observers who have been at practice say
things look normal and I'm going to see
with my own eyes here later today all
right Jim moving over to the NFC uh Nate
here has been schooling Galen I on the
Rock Purdy story and why he's called Mr
Irrelevant last pick of not the first
round of the draft but of the whole dang
draft and now he's won I think seven
straight games in the NFL and he's
facing the Eagles on Sunday they seem to
have the upper hand based on how
dominant they were against the Giants
what does Brock need to do to bring this
home to San Francisco
listen this is a story when the when the
season began and no one and Nate you and
I we follow this thing so closely no one
knew who Brock Purdy was so yes the last
pick in the draft Mr Irrelevant could
come into being the most relevant guy of
all who knows but going into
Philadelphia they are playing so well in
every single facet they've got home
field that San Francisco defense it's a
great matchup I don't know I mean Purdy
right now uh it's just it's beyond
description he's on his way to maybe
seizing that starting quarterback role
at San Francisco for years to come
yeah it says a lot about their coaching
staff and Kyle Shanahan and what he's
been able to do with three quarterbacks
this season uh but Jim I wanted to get
your thoughts on a long time colleague
Billy Packer who passed away at 82. what
was his legacy and what should it be
I think Billy
will go down in history as one of the
greatest analysts in the history of of
sports television I I think that when
you start looking at the pantheon of
great analysts you've got you've got
John Madden you've got Billy Packer and
you start right there he blessed this
network for a long time from 1982 until
he retired in 2008 one of my dearest
friends it's been a restless night
thinking of uh of the family the Packer
Family which I'm very close to I got to
speak to Billy the day before he died
and tell him I love them and I don't
know he was he was a genius I mean there
was there was no one who could just look
at the field in this case look at the
court and see everything and he's going
to be very much missed but he he loved
college basketball and he looked after
it as a guardian of his sport and he's
just a giant and a giant heart that's
all I can tell you is um as a husband
looking after Barb his wife who
has health concerns and issues the last
15 20 years of her life that was he he
said his greatest fulfillment was
looking after her an incredible father
grandfather and friend
he will be missed uh Jim looking forward
to seeing you on Sunday I hear it's
going to be a little nippy so make sure
you dress warm all right
I'm packing right now as we speak Nate
I'm I'm looking forward to it but I'll
be carrying I'll be carrying Billy right
here in my heart thank you pal yeah good
luck on the call and I know you'll be
calling golf as well and you can watch
Jim on the Farmer's Insurance open today
and then of course you can see it on CBS
and Paramount plus then tune in on
Sunday for the AFC championship between
the Bengals and the Chiefs this Sunday
with coverage from Kansas City kicking
off at 6 PM Eastern